I want to take up in volume three at June the 20th, 1900 so we're dealing with a whole group of
messages to do with the chastisements and I've already explained that and then the need for humility
and nothingness on our part. So the message this time is humility and nothingness and also the next
one. This morning as I was outside of myself, Louisa said, and not finding my highest good,
I had to go round and round in search of him and when I tired myself to the point of feeling faint,
I felt him behind my shoulders sustaining me. My beloved, you know that I can't be without you
and yet you make me wait so much to the point of causing me to faint. Tell me at least what is
the cause of this? Jesus has told her many times what the cause is but Louisa always comes to the
conclusion that it's something to do with herself. Louisa said, tell me at least what is the cause of
this? Where have I offended you that you subject me to torment so cruel to martyrdom so painful
which is your privation? And Jesus interrupting me said, my daughter, my daughter, do not add more
torment to my heart which is embittered to the summit, finding itself in a continuous fight because
of the violence that everyone does to me continuously. The iniquities of men do violence to me as they
draw justice upon themselves and force me to chastise them. Notice they force me. And justice
clashing in a continuous fight with the love I have for human beings tortures my heart in such a
painful way as to make me die continuously. You do violence to me. That's Matthew 11 12 which I've
given to you before. You do violence to me because when I come knowing the chastisements that I am
sending you do not remain quiet but you force me you do violence to me you do not want me to chastise
and knowing that you cannot do otherwise in my presence so as not to expose my heart to an even
worse fight I abstain from coming. Therefore do not want to force me to come for now. Let me give
vent to my fury and do not want to increase my pains with your speaking. That's absolutely
incredible. Nobody would expect that we could have that kind of an effect on the Lord but of course
we're dealing with Louisa and her unique relationship with God. As for the rest he said, I do not want
you to think about it because the most perfect the most sublime humility is that of losing every
reasoning and not discoursing on the why and the how on doing oneself in one's own nothingness.
This is an extremely important statement. Jesus says that all the rationalizing we do
doesn't help remotely. It doesn't help us. It doesn't help the Lord. But it's an attempt on
our part to try and get some kind of control and we don't like not being in control when we're adults.
So surrendering to the Lord on this point is actually very difficult. Now at the same time
that the Lord is saying this to Louisa rationalism is coming into the church in a huge way and it's
going to destroy faith. The more they rationalize the faith the less they can really believe and so
has done immense harm. We're living the bitter fruits of it a century later. So he asks her instead
to go into her own nothingness and to let him work because he works best in nothingness. So I want
to give you two Corinthians 12 and nine. My power works best in weakness, okay? And we've plenty of
weakness to give him, haven't we? So while the soul does this Jesus said without realizing it she
finds herself dissolved in God who has the answer to everything. We've no answers to anything. And
this produces in the soul the union which is most intimate, the love that is most perfect towards
her highest good. This however is to the greatest advantage of the soul because in losing her own
reasoning she acquires the divine reasoning and in losing every discoursing about herself whether
she's cold or warm and with things that happen to her are favorable or adverse she will be interested
in and will acquire the language that is fully celestial and divine. Now that is such a major
statement that you need to read it over and over and over again. Let me give you Matthew 2312
where Jesus told the scribes and Pharisees that because of the way they were thinking and
reasoning and rationalizing they were destroying faith in everybody else. I want to give you Isaiah
55 verses 8 to 10 where the Lord says, "My thoughts are not your thoughts, my ways are not your ways,
my ways and my thoughts are as different from yours as the heavens are from the earth." And what
Jesus is asking Louisa and the rest of us is that we can choose between the earthly way
and the heavenly way. And if we want to choose the heavenly way what we have to do is throw ourselves
into our nothingness and let God be God. So I want to give you also Colossians 3 12 there.
So what you achieve is a way of thinking that is divine, absolute, different from the world.
In addition to this humility produces a garment of safety in the soul. For that I wanted to give
you two chronicles 34-27. And this garment of safety is such that wrapped in this garment of
safety the soul remains in the most profound cam, Philippians 4-7, the peace that passes all
understanding and guards our heart and our mind in Christ Jesus. And also Isaiah 26-3,
you will keep him in perfect peace whose mind is stayed on you because he trusts in you. So
the Lord is asking us just a few of us who are willing to at least try and live at the divine
level. He's asking us to trust him beyond reason and to let him be God because the others are all
refusing to let him be God they want to be gods themselves. So with this garment of safety the
soul remains in the most profound cam embellishing all of herself in order to be pleasing to her
dearest and beloved Jesus. So I want to give you there one Peter 1 5-9 that if we bow before the
power of God he will raise us up. Who can say how surprised I was left with this teaching of his
Louisa said. I'd not a word to answer him that's something for her. Then after a little while he
disappeared and I found myself inside of myself that's back out of the ecstasy. Cam yes but afflicted
the summit first because of the afflictions and the fights which my dear Jesus was in and then out
of fear that he mightn't come again. Who would be able to endure? How will I be able to even bear
myself that is pop with yourself because of his absence? Now Louisa's saying something very important.
That we can get ourselves into such a tizzy we're not only unbearable to everybody else we're
actually unbearable to ourselves as well. "A Lord" she said give me the strength to bear this
martyrdom which is so hard so unbearable for my poor soul. After all say whatever you want but
I will not neglect any means I will try always I will use all strategies to draw you to come.
Talk about forcing him. Talk about doing violence to him. I want to give you SAM 63 oh God you are
my God for you I long for you my soul is thirsting even my body is crying out for you like a dry
weary land without water. So June the 24th 1900 and Jesus tells us that the cross is actually
the nourishment for humility. After going through a few days of privation at the most a few shadows
and flashes she said I felt all my powers asleep now that's the intellect memory and will in the
sleep of contemplation. In such a way that I myself could not understand what was happening in my
interior. In this sleepiness only one pain was awake in my interior and it was the fact that it
seemed it had happened to me as to one who while sleeping loses his sight or is deprived of all
his riches. The miserable one can neither grieve nor defend himself nor use some means to free himself
from his misfortunes. The poor one in what a pitiful state he finds himself but what was the cause of
it his sleep. Now what the Lord has done with Louisa is to put her into this state of sleepiness
to try and calm down the crisis that's in her soul but she doesn't think that it is a gift of his
not yet anyway. Do you remember in Mark chapter 13 verses 33 to 37 Jesus found the apostles asleep
when they should have been awake but in in Louisa's case it's actually very different he has actually
done this to try and calm her down. So what is the cause of this? His sleep because if he had been
awake he would certainly have known how to defend himself well from his misfortunes.
"Such is my miserable state," she said. "It's not given to me even to be allowed a moan, a sigh or
to shed a tear because I've lost sight of the one who is all my love, all my good and who forms
all my contentment." She's one with the divine will now but it's only volume three and she won't
get the explanation of this until volumes 11 and 12 the Lord wants to have her well established
in the divine will before he uses any words towards her. It seems that in order not to make me grieve
from his privation he has made me fall asleep and left me. Now she has come to the correct conclusion
that exactly what he has done to try and help her to remain calm. "A lord wake me up yourself," she
said, "so that I may see my miseries and know at least what I am being deprived of." She's expressing
it rather well for someone who's supposed to be asleep. Now while I was in this state from within
my interior I heard Blessed Jesus moaning continuously. So there I want to give you Luke 17 21, the
kingdom of goddess within you and one Corinthians 3 16, "No you not that you are the temple of the
living God and the spirit of God dwells in you." "Those moans," she said, "wounded my hearing and
waking up a little bit," I said, "my soul and only good from your moans," I perceive the very painful
state that you are in. This happens because you want to suffer by yourself and you don't want to let
me share your pains even more. So as not to have me in your company you made me fall asleep and you
left me without letting me understand anything anymore. I understand where this all comes from.
It is so that you may be more free to do the chastising, but pleased," she said, "have
compassion on me for I am blind without you," Sam 36 verse 9, "in your light, Lord, we see light."
She said, "I'm blind without you," and "on yourself," she said, "it is always good in all
circumstances to have someone who would keep you company, who would relieve you and somehow break
your fury." In fact, now you are determined and you send chastisement, but when you see your images,
now that's Genesis 1 27 and Romans 8 29, but when you see your images perish from misery,
you will let out more moans than now and maybe you will even say, ah, if you had tried harder to
placate me, if you had taken the pains of the others upon yourself, I would not see my own
members so tormented. His own members means the members of the body of Christ, 1 Corinthians 12,
12 to 13. "Isn't it true, my most patient Jesus," she said, "please relieve yourself a little bit
and let me suffer in your place." While I was saying this, he moaned continuously almost in the act of
wanting to be sympathized and relieved, but he wanted this relief to be snatched almost by force,
she says. She's coming to realize that the Lord wants her to work harder. So after my importunity,
importunity is that you insist you insist you insist. Do you remember Luke 18 verses 1 to 10,
the widow and the unjust judge, she would have gotten nothing out of that judge if she hadn't
persisted continuously in her request. So after my importunity, he stretched out his nailed hands
and feet in my interior, so this is not something exterior to herself and shared a little bit of
his pains with me. "Giving a little respite to his moans," he told me, "my daughter in these
very sad times that force me to this, because men have grown so bold and so proud that everyone
thinks he's a god himself." Now, self-worship or ontology, A-U-T-O-L, ontology is the worship
of self is the final insult to God, that the nothing worships itself before the all.
Everyone thinks he's a god of himself, and if I do not lay hand discourages, I would do harm to
their souls, because the cross alone is the nourishment of humility. So he's saying that the
discourages are a cross. This is very important, okay? The chastisements, I'm writing it down,
the chastisements are a cross. Now that's a new way of looking at the chastisements,
and he says that the chastisements are the only thing that can bring any level of humility.
So I want to give you Isaiah 2, verses 9, 11 and 17, which says that the pride of man must be brought
low if God's will is to be done on earth. So Jesus said, "I will do harm to their souls,
if I don't do it, because the cross alone is the nourishment of humility." So if I did not do this,
I myself would cause them to lack the means to be humiliated and to stop their strange madness.
Their strange madness is that, you know, they've been all created in the image and likeness of God,
and Satan has managed to blind the human race to such an extent that the human race is actually
worshiping itself and worshiping its own achievements. So, and he said, "Even though the majority of
them are actually offending me more, but I act like a father who breaks the bread for all to be
nourished." Now that's Psalm 103 verses 13 to 14, "As tenderly as a father treats his children,
so the Lord treats those who fear him." So this is a bread which some of the children don't want
to take even more. They use it to throw it in their father's face. What has the poor father
done wrong? He said, "That's what I'm like." The father hasn't done anything wrong. It's the
rebellion that's in the children. So having said this, he disappeared, leaving me half away, half
asleep, not knowing myself whether I have woken up completely or I go back to sleep. So she's not
left in the row at this particular point. So things are pretty awful midway between the year 1900.
So June the 27th, 1900, the soul must recognize herself in Jesus and not in herself. So this is
all about self-forgetfulness. Now the 20th century, which is the century that started as starting
ourselves and push yourself and glorify yourself and do everything for yourself.
It's not the century of humility, unfortunately. And so the Lord has to teach us the hard way
how to humble ourselves before the power of God. So Louisa says, "I continue to be sleepy.
This morning for a few minutes I found myself awake and I understood my miserable state.
I felt the bitterness of the privation of my highest and only good. I was only able to
shed a few tears, saying to him, "My good Jesus, how is it that you're not coming?" These are
not things to do to wound the soul and then leave her. To wound the soul means that you have got
through to her and you've got her to the point where she's madly in love with you and then you
walk off. And what is more? So as not to let her know what you're doing, you make her a prey to
sleep. She said, "Please don't do that. Don't make me wait so much. So I want to give you Isaiah 40-31.
Those who wait upon the Lord shall renew their strength. They shall mount up with wings like
the eagle. They shall run and not be weary. They shall walk and not faint." So while I was saying
this, Louisa said, and yet more nonsense, in one instant Jesus came and transported me outside of
myself. And since I wanted to tell him about my poor state, imposing silence on me, Jesus told
me, "My daughter, what I want from you, notice how clear the divine will is. What I want from you
is that you no longer recognize yourself in yourself, but that you recognize yourself only in me."
Now that's Galatians 2-20, "I no longer live. Christ lives in me." Now while Louisa will acknowledge
that Jesus is living within her, at the same time she talks and seems to act as if this isn't true.
So he said, "You will no longer remember yourself, nor will you ever again have recognition
of yourself, but you will remember me, and unrecognizing yourself, you will acquire
the recognition of me alone." So I want to give you two Corinthians 3-18. You can read the text
yourself, but it says that the more we contemplate the Lord, the more we are transformed into the
image that we contemplate. And the Lord wants somebody who loves him at the level that Louisa loves
him to just simply forget themselves, stay in that absolute nothingness, and let God be all in
all. And if they're looking at him morning, noon, and night, then they will end up glorifying and
praising him forever. You'll see this as we go on in the writings that this will become a reality for
Louisa. Jesus continues, "According to how much you forget and destroy yourself." Now we can't
destroy ourselves, but he means you put aside your ego, that your ego isn't ruling your life.
So gradually we hand over, we push the ego aside, we say, "Not my will, but thine be done, we hand
over our will, we hand it over, we hand it over until eventually the Lord knows he can actually take it."
So according to how much you will forget and destroy yourself, so will you advance in the knowledge
of me. It's really sad that there are many people who claim to know the Lord, and in actual fact,
they know him very little. They've got religion, they've got piety, but they don't have personal
knowledge of God. It's the personal knowledge of God that makes the difference. You will advance
in knowledge of me and will recognize yourself only in me. Once you've done this, once you have
done this, you will no longer think with your mind, but with mine. You will no longer look
with your eyes, you will no longer speak with your mouth, nor will you palpitate with your heart,
work with your hands, or walk with your feet, but you'll do everything with mine. That's where we're
going. So I want to give you Philippians 2.5, let this mind be in you. That was also in Christ,
Jesus. In fact, in order to recognize yourself only in God, the soul needs to go to her origin
and to return to her beginning, which of course is God himself, from whom she came,
and she needs to conform all of herself to her Creator. Okay, that means the fulfillment of
Deuteronomy 6, verses 4 to 10. Here, O Israel, the Lord your God is one Lord, and you shall love
the Lord your God with all your heart, with all your soul, with all your mind, and with all your
being. Now, notice the all all the time. Most of us love God with a little bit, but he wants it all.
He's a lover, and he has a right to it. He's our Creator. And anything which she keeps of herself,
Jesus says, and which is not conformed to her beginning, she must undo and reduce to nothing.
Galatians 5, 24. Only in this way, naked, on dawn, can she return to her origin and recognize
herself only in God. Now, this stripping of all that is worldly, and all that is selfish, and self,
and all the rest of it, that is absolutely essential. If it doesn't happen, we're actually not going
anywhere. There are people who are prepared to say the divine will prayers, but they're now
willing to let the Lord strip them and clothe them with himself. Only in this way, naked,
on dawn, can she return to her origin, recognize herself only in God, and operate according to the
purpose for which she was created. Now, if you look at the beginning of your book, you'll see
that the whole divine will spirituality is the call of the creature to return to the order,
the place, and the purpose for which it was created. That's what the Lord is trying to do with us,
is get us back to our origin and back into the image that he actually created in us,
and also into the relationship. So he said, "This is why in order to conform to me completely,
the soul must render herself indivisible with me." That's no small order. That's a very tall order.
Indivisible with him. Now, if we're conforming to the world in any way, we're certainly not
indivisible with him. So I want to give you John 14, 20 to 21, you and me and I in you, both completely
one. So while you were saying this, I could see the terrible chastisement of Vance withered,
and how it must advance even further. And I could only say, "How, Lord, how will the poor people go on?"
And he saw as not to listen to me, escape like a flash and disappear. Who can say, "The bitterness
of my soul in finding myself, back to myself, not having been able to speak to him?" Even one word
for him, "Myself." Find that funny. Since the message has been, "Forget yourself, see yourself
only in me, become indivisible with me." But we don't take things on board the first time they're
told. Sometimes we have to be told many times before it really registers what we've heard.
We might have heard the words, but not the understanding. And she said, "How will I continue?"
So June the 28th, 1900, this is a big prophetic message that the present chastisements in the year
1900 are merely a prophetic forecast of the huge chastisements that are coming in the 20th century,
which of course are the two world wars. So I want to give you Amos 3, 7, and Isaiah 64, 10. The Lord
never does anything without telling the prophets first. This morning, as I was highly afflicted
because of the privation of my loving Jesus, Louisa says, "I saw him for just a little, and
he told me, my daughter, how many masks will be unmasked in these times of chastisement."
Now there are even other extremely important statement about chastisement. The 20th century
was the century of deception. And one of the great deceptions that is still with us, and in fact it
has become worldwide fashion, is love. And you're going to say to me, "How can love be a deception?"
Ah, you see, what they call love is not actually love. If you pull back the label on the bottle,
you'll find lost behind it. That's the deception. That they're calling all kinds of sinful behavior
love. That they're throwing out God's laws to make their own laws, to make room for this other
thing that they're calling love. But it's not love, it's lust, it's deception. And that's what he means
that how many masks will be unmasked in these times of chastisements. And the chastisement that
pulls back the veil on reality and people begin to see. In fact, these present chastisements are
nothing but the predisposition for all the chastisements which I manifested to you during the course
of last year. So you see, she's seeing everything ahead of time. The Lord showed her World War I
ahead of time. He showed her World War II ahead of time. But when you actually get into World War II,
Jesus said, look, leave them at it. They want to kill each other. Let you and I create a future full
of hope for them. So as Jesus was saying this in my interior, Louisa said, if the Lord continues
to behave the way he's behaving. And since he wants to send chastisements, he does not come.
He does not share his pains with me and treats me with unusual ways. Who's going to be able to
endure this? And who will give me the strength to remain in this state? And Jesus answering my
thought that only God can read our thoughts added in in an act of compassion. So do you want me to
suspend your state of victim soul for a while? In other words, do you want to get out of this?
And to resume later, as he said this, Louisa said, I felt such confusion and bitterness for
it seemed to me that with this proposal, the Lord was driving me away from himself.
Because if she stepped out of her victim soul status, she was also stepping out of this extraordinary
intimacy she was given by the Lord. So she said, I was unable to say either yes or no, also in order
to hear what the priest, the spiritual director would decide. So without waiting for my word,
Jesus disappeared from me, leaving me as though a nail was struck in my heart, thinking that Jesus
was rejecting me. The pain was so great that I did nothing but shed bitter tears. Okay.
So Louisa's caught in a terrible situation. She's desperately tempted to get out of this state that
she's in. If Jesus isn't coming all the time, and if he isn't giving her reparations to do all the
time, she will learn what to do later on when she learns how to act more fully in the divine will.
June the 29th, 1900, Jesus and Louisa refresh each other. As I continued to be
embittered, my adorable Jesus having compassion for me came and seemed to sustain me in his arms,
noticed the seemed it's not completely clear. Then he transported me outside of myself,
and I saw that a profound silence, a sadness, a mourning reigned everywhere. The impression my
soul received on seeing people that way was to really make a grip on my heart. And then as though
calling me aside, blessed Jesus said my daughter, let us move what afflicts us away from us for a
while and let us refresh each other. Now this profound silence, this sadness, this mourning,
raining everywhere is going to be the desperate result of the world wars. Millions of people dead,
cities, everything utterly devastated, the people just not knowing what to do next.
But the amazing things we recover and we make more wars. So then as though calling me aside,
blessed Jesus said to me, my daughter, let us move aside and refresh each other. While saying
this began to kiss me and caress, what my confusion was such that I didn't dare to return them. And
he said, how come? I refresh you with kisses and caresses and you don't want to refresh me by
returning your kisses and so on. And then I felt the confidence to give him a tit for a touch,
she said, it's just necessary to know that this is happening on a spiritual plane, not on a physical
plane. So July the second 1900, with her sufferings, Louisa holds back a chastisement. I continued to
be embittered and afflicted as though dazed. This morning Jesus didn't come at all. The confessor
came and placed the intention of the crucifixion. Now, when the confessor in the name of the church
asks for Louisa to be given the crucifixion, then the church is taking action in order to
intercede with God for the chastisements to be mitigated. And the Lord will always recognize the
power and the authority of the priest. At first place, Jesus did not concur, but then after I prayed
him today to let me obey, he just barely made himself seen and he said to me, what do you want?
Why do you do violence to me by force? That's Matthew 11, 12. When it is necessary to chastise
the people. And Louisa said, Lord, it's not me, it's obedience that wants it. So in other words,
it's the church that's asking you officially, but I'm the one that must carry out the function
because you've given me this office of victim soul. And he said, well, then, since it is obedience,
in other words, he accepts the authority of the church, I want to share with you my crucifixion.
And in the meantime, I want to refresh myself a little bit while saying this, he shared with me
the pains of the cross. And while I was suffering, Jesus placed himself near me and seemed to refresh
himself quite a bit. Now, while I was in this position together with him, he showed me a pitch
black cloud approaching from one point of the air. You're talking about a hurricane,
such that it struck terror and frightened the mere sight of it. And everyone was saying,
this time we die. While all were terrified, a ruffulgent cross rose from between Jesus and me,
and advancing towards that storm, put it to flight in great part. So much so that the people
seemed to calm down. That Sam 107 verse 29, the Lord calming the storm. I cannot tell for sure,
but it seems to me that it was a hurricane accompanied by bolts of lightning and hail so violent as to
have the power to sweep factories away. And the cross which dispelled it seemed to be my little
suffering. That's Isaiah 28 to wish the Lord had shared with me. And so she thanks the Lord for that.
So here you see the power of the victim soul able to genuinely make a difference on planet earth,
because the office of victim soul is accepted and respected by God. And therefore, the victim soul
is allowed to make this kind of intercession, which you and I ordinary folks wouldn't have the power
to do at all. So July the third 1900, we have more chastisements. This morning, having received
communion, as soon as I saw my adorable Jesus, I said to him, my beloved good, how is it that
you are sending so many chastisements? You see, Louisa doesn't realize what's going on with the
communism and the atheism and all the rest of it. All she sees is what the Lord actually shows her.
And he keeps on giving her graphic images. And a graphic image like a terrible hurricane
is to stimulate her to have the motivation to be able to do something to stop it.
She said, Lord, why don't you pour your bitterness into me? It has not been your usual way to act
like this. And when I was saying this, Jesus interrupted me and he said, yet my daughter,
the chastisements I'm sending are still nothing compared to those which have been prepared. That's
the two world wars. Therefore, don't want to afflict yourself about this because they're not a matter
for great affliction. It's not interesting. Jesus says, look, don't sweat over these ones.
There's plenty more. And as he was saying this, in front of me, I saw many people affected by
contagious diseases who were dying. I want to give you Sam 38 verse seven and Sam 41 verse eight.
Now, we do know that in the early part of the 20th century, there were terrible contagious
diseases going around. In the late 20th century, we have the cancer, the AIDS, we had the TB,
we had the diphtheria in the early part of the century. Just to give you a couple of examples.
And the people were dying. So taken by horror, I said to our Lord, that's all we need. What are you
doing? What are you doing? If you want to do this, you said, just take me from the earth, from my
heart can't stand the sight of scenes that are so gloomy. Now, this is one of Louise's big temptations.
Take me out of here. I don't want any more of it. But the point is when she says that
she doesn't realize she's offending against the very office that the Lord has given to her to stand
in the breach and to intercede for humanity. Now, I mean, she's a human being. I'm not criticizing
her. I just think it's fantastic what she's able to do. Besides, Louise said, who can endure
continuing in this state, which you put me in, that you do not come and you only come like a shadow
and not only this, you leave me dazed and sleepy, not letting me understand anything anymore.
Yet you told me that you would leave me like this until you would somehow give vent to your fury.
But now you've added fury to fury and it seems you will not be done. She said, poor me, poor me,
who will give me the strength to remain in this state? Okay. So the wrath of God is something
that the Old Testament speaks about quite a bit. So I want to give you Sam 78 31 and 49. Sam 88 76,
Sam 89 46, Sam 102 10 106 40, etc, etc, etc. But you know what the wrath of God is, don't you? That
sins go up from the earth. Nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of God and they're sent
right back to us in chastisements. So this stuff came from the earth and it actually goes back to
the earth, but it in very simple language. So Louisa said, while I poured out my affliction,
sympathizing with me, Jesus said, my daughter, do not be concerned by your state of sleepiness.
This says that I am with the people as if I were sleeping. Now Louisa therefore is getting an update
as to what's actually going on, that she has to experience what Jesus is experiencing. Okay.
And therefore this is a very important explanation that Jesus gives to her here. Don't be concerned,
he said, this says that just as I am with the people as if I were sleeping, that's Mark 4 38,
Jesus sleeping in the boat, as if I did not hear them or look at them in that same state I have
placed you. Now from here on in, he will place her in the position that he's actually in and she's
got to learn that it's out of that position that she intercedes instead of complaining that she's in
it, that it's out of that position she should do it. Like for example, in Mark 4 38, when Jesus was
asleep during the storm, the apostles woke him up and it was standing there in the storm that he
dealt with it. When you have the three men in the fiery furnace in the book of Daniel chapter three,
and they are praising and glorifying God, what God does, what God doesn't do is to put fire out.
That wouldn't have said anything to the pagan king. What God did was he sent an angel into the
fire and it was the action of the angel in the fire that actually made all the difference to the
pagans outside. So after all, Jesus said, if you mind it, I told you last time, do you want me to
suspend your state of victim? You see, the priests, unfortunately, are not able to explain to Louisa
what's going on. They're depending on her getting messages from the Lord and then they understand.
So the poor girl is in a no place place and that unless the Lord explains to her very clearly,
she doesn't know what's going on. That's a very difficult position to be in. And so Louisa said,
"Lord, obedience doesn't want me to accept this suspension." He said, "Okay, be quiet and obey."
Oh, well, who can say how afflicted I remain? She said, not only this, but I was left asleep
and I had to just put up with it. So July the 9th, 1900, this is a very important one. We have to
live not only for God, but in God. I continue in usual state, she said, maybe even worse.
And if sometimes he makes himself seen, it's like a shadow and flashes.
But almost always, she said, it's silence. This morning, as I was in the summit of my affliction
and dazedness because of the continuous sleep, he just barely made himself seen and told me,
courage, my daughter, the soul who is truly mine must live not only for God, but in God.
You should try to live in me. That's John 14, 20 to 21. For in me, you will find the receptacle
of all virtues and strolling in their midst, you will nourish yourself with their fragrance,
so much so as to become replete or full. Okay. So Jesus says to her, "Don't just live for God,
live in him." That's like saying, don't just live for the ocean that you think it's absolutely
wonderful. Live in it. Let the ocean be your life and let all your being come from that ocean.
That's the way the fish live. They're in the ocean. So if you ask them, where is the water,
they might know what the answer is because it's just part of their existence.
So he said, and it's it's in living in him that you get all the strength of all the virtues
and you yourself will do nothing but give off light and celestial fragrance. That's Matthew 5 17,
let your light shine because to live in me is true virtue and true virtue has the power of giving
to the soul the same shape as the divine person in whom she dwells and of transforming her
into the very divine virtues in which she nourishes herself. Now that's the two Corinthians 3, 18 again.
And so Jesus is saying, if you would plunge yourself into the divine being and just live there
and instead of living for God, then you would be transformed into the divine. You would be
divinized. So after this he disappeared like a flash and running after that flash my soul found
herself outside of myself. But he'd already escaped and it was not given to me to find him.
That's a very important statement because people in the new age are able to force themselves into
an out-of-the-body experience and they write books on their astral projections and all the rest of
their planetary travels and all the rest of it. But out there in that universe there's only God
and Satan. There isn't anything else. And so Louisa is saying, I can't bring this on myself because
she is operating with the Lord and in him in as much as it's actually possible. And so she says
it isn't given to me to find him while I receive the bitterness of seeing a terrible hail which
is going to cause awful devastation and bolts of lightning as if they were going to produce fires.
So I want to give you Exodus 9, 18 to 34, the terrible plague of hail. And I want to give for
lightning I want to give you Sam 1, 3, 5, verse 7. Okay. And I just want to give you a tiny little
thought. And that is that God is light, 1 John 1, 5. And this light comes to us in a very benign,
wonderful way through on a physical level, through the sun, for example, to give us a life on the
earth and to empower us and encourage us and help growth and all the rest of it. Lightning therefore
must be an expression of the wrath of God because it comes to us in a staccato way and it strikes
the earth. It's not benign. It's not wonderful like that. So July the 10th, 1900. This is a very
important explanation of the difference between living for God and living in him that we've just
been talking about. While I was in some confusion, Louisa said, Jesus made himself seen in a flash
and made me understand that I had not written everything that he told me the day before. Now,
she's been told this from the beginning. And she's going to need a lot of encouragement to really say
what God says to her. And it's only in the higher volumes that will get the whole thing.
I'm supposed to say that the soul must not only live for God, but in him. So blessed Jesus
repeated to me the difference that exists between living for God and living in God. Saying to me,
in living for God, the soul can be subject to disturbance, to bitterness, to being in constant,
to feeling the weight of the passions, to meddle with earthly things, and so on. This is the ordinary
level that we're all used to. But living in God know it's completely different because the most
important thing for one that a person may enter to dwell inside another person is to lay down
all that belongs to him. So it's complete surrender. There must be complete surrender.
For one person to enter to dwell inside another is to lay down all that belongs to him. That is
to strip himself of everything, to leave his own passions in a word, to leave everything in order
to find everything in God. Galatians 5, 24. Now we've been told since volume one that we have to
drip ourselves of the world and the flesh and the devil and all the rest of it, and that we have to
put the ego aside, get into our nothingness and let God begin to work with us. Okay, we've told
this. And as we go on, this will be explained more and more clearly. So here, I want to give you a
tiny little image. If you light two candles, the wact is no use now for this image. If you light
two candles, you can put the two flames together and they will become one flame. Both flames occupying
exactly the same space as one of them would. That's living in God. I'm not separate from him.
So when the soul has not only stripped herself, but has slimmed down, well, I love that expression,
we've got to slim down our pride, our self sufficiency, our self reliance, ourself, ourself, ourself,
ourself, ourself. When the soul has slimmed down well, then will she be able to enter through the
narrow door of my heart to live in me according to my way and from my own life? Okay. Jesus said that
the narrow way is the way to God, that Matthew 713 to 14. But in Luke 1324, he says that those who
humble themselves will be exalted. And of course, the more you humble yourself, the more you can be
exalted. Let me illustrate that for you. If people want to build a skyscraper, this is a building
that's going to go higher than other buildings, huge thing that has got to take the wind and the
storms and the hurricanes and everything else to do that. They've got to put the foundations lower
and lower and lower and lower than all other buildings. Because if the foundations are not deep,
the skyscraper won't stay up. So the higher we want to go in union with God, the lower we have to go
in humility. So John 14, six as well, because Jesus is the way, the truth and the life.
So let me read that again. When a soul has not only stripped herself, but a slim down well,
then she will be able to enter through the narrow door of my heart to live in me according to my
way and from my own life. In fact, even though my heart is immense, so much so there's no end to
its boundaries, because naturally enough, he's infinite. Its door, however, is extremely narrow
and only one who is stripped of everything can enter into it. Now I've said to you before and
you'll probably hear me saying it again endlessly. And that is when you are taking flight for heaven,
there's no baggage allowance. You're not allowed to take anything. The only thing you can take with
you is love, because that's the substance of heaven. Everything else has to go. And one of the
reasons why thumb souls really struggle in their dying is that they have to let go and let go and
let go. And it can be agonizing to let go and let go. And the more attached they were to things,
the harder it is to let go. But for a child, there's no problem. They just close their eyes and go.
So the door for entering the Sacred Heart is only for one who has been stripped of everything.
Okay, and this is with reason, because since I am most holy, I would never admit anything to live
in me which is outside of me. Oh dear, let me give you these references again. Isaiah 35 verses 8 to 10.
The unclean can't travel this path. Revelation 21, 27, and Revelation 22, 15, in the new Jerusalem
where everybody's living for and in God, all sinners have to be outside. Matthew 5, 8, only the pure
heart can see God. And Hebrews 12, 14, nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of God.
Let me read this again. Since I am most holy, I would never admit anything to live in me which is
extraneous or outside or strange to my sanctity. And therefore my daughter try to live in me and
you will possess paradise in advance. A lady you might never have heard of, sister Madeleine
Duclerc, she founded an Order of Religious Sisters some hundred or two years ago. One of her great
statements is that the surrendered soul has found paradise on earth. So July the 11th, 1900,
the sufferings of Louisa will render chastisement less rigorous. At this particular point,
Louisa isn't yet aware that her privations are actually an important part of her suffering for
others. She's been told at many times, but she doesn't get it. I'm away chastising and she's
an agony. Only sometimes does she actually make an offering of this agony to him out of love,
but she will eventually realize that it is actually part of her intercession.
This morning, having received communion and continue in the same state of confusion as I've been,
I was all huddled within myself when I saw my adorable Jesus coming towards me all in a hurry
and he said, "My daughter, break my fury a little bit otherwise." Another was something drastic
that happened and Louisa all frightened said, "What do you want me to do to break your fury?"
And he said, "By calling my sufferings into yourself, you will come to placate my fury."
At that moment, I saw as if he were calling the confessor by sending a ray of light that's infused
knowledge and immediately the priest placed the intention of having me suffer the crucifixion.
This time now, whatever has happened on the earth, the Lord wants them to intervene.
And so if God wants it, that's okay. So this time, the Lord actually gives the thought to the priest
to place the intention for Louisa. And Louisa is in such a spiritual state that she can actually
see what's going on. The blessed Lord promptly concurred with the priest and I found myself
in so many sufferings that because of the intensity of the pains, I felt my soul go out of my body.
Now, that's one of the ways in which you can actually bring on and out of the body experience,
which is really intense pain. It's known, for example, that in the past when dangerous prisoners
would be put into a straight jacket, the straight jacket was such a horrendous suffocating pain
for the person that they'd often go into and out of the body experience just to survive.
Because of the intensity of the pains, I felt my soul go out of my body, she said.
And I thought I was about to breathe my last and I was content that Jesus would receive my soul.
But I saw the confessor who was saying enough, enough, and was calling me back into myself.
And Jesus said to me, "Obedience is calling you." You know? And I said, "Oh, Lord, what can I do?"
"Obedience keeps calling you," he said. And so it seems that this new obedience did not allow
the sufferings to go any further because the priest doesn't want her to die and the priest
is already told or she doesn't have permission to die. I think Louisa may be the only person
on the planet who's ever been told she didn't have permission to die. And she said, "Indeed,
this is a cruel obedience for me because while I seem to seize the harbor, that is eternal life,
I was flung outside to navigate the way back." So I want to give you two Corinthians chapter five
verses one to ten where St. Paul said that he wanted to take off the tent of this life and go
and be with the Lord, but that he realized that the will of God wanted him to stay and so he chose
to stay for the sake of God's will. Then afterwards Louisa said, "Even though I was left in suffering,
I no longer felt that thing of being about to die and my benign Jesus returned. My daughter,
if today you had not broken my fury," he said, "I had reached such a limit that I would have
destroyed not only plants but also people." And if the Confessor himself had not intervened
by calling my suffering into you, I would have had no regard for him either.
So what Jesus is saying is that it really is time for the priests to cut on about the seriousness
of what is going on and the seriousness of using Louisa as the victim soul to help us.
"It's true that the chastisements are necessary," he said, "but every now and then,
when my fury advances, it is necessary that you break it. Otherwise, my daughter, how many more
scourges I would send? And while he was saying this, I seemed to see him all tired, saying while
mourning my daughter or my children, poor children of mine, how reduced I see you. Now what he's moaning
about is the frightful moral state of the human race. And to my surprise, he made me understand
that after he had calmed down a little bit, he was to resume his fury to continue the chastisements
and that this had only served to make him not rage too much." Oops, against the people. "Our
Lord," she said, "plicate yourself." So I'll give you just one more because it's short and it's part
of this message. This is July the 14th, 1900. "It seems I've spent a few days without being immersed
in this lethargy of sleep and together with blessed Jesus a little bit, giving a little refreshment
to each other. But how I fear that he may plunge me again into that sleep which is so profound.
Then this morning, after he had refreshed me with milk, now I personally don't understand the milk,
except to say to you that when a child receives milk from its mother, it's receiving life and all
the nourishment for life. Louisa is living a completely miraculous life. According to ordinary medical
statements, Louisa should be dead. She should have got osteoporosis and she should have got muscle
wasted and she should have got all kinds of things. But she got none of that because the Lord sustains
her. So I just can't say definitively just my ignorance, whether this milk is completely spiritual
food or whether it feeds the body as well. So he refreshed me with milk that flowed from his mouth
by pouring it into me and I refreshed him by removing the crown of thorns from his head to drive it into
mine. And all afflicted he said to me, my daughter, the decree of chastisements is signed. In other
words, the die is cast. There's nothing left but to decide the time of its execution. Now the
chastisements are World War one and two. And I want to give you Isaiah 28, 28. And I want to give
you Revelation 10, 6. The wait is over. So anything that Louisa could have done to actually stop the
wars that time is over, the wars will happen and the Lord will show Louisa how to respond from here
on in. So we'll stop there.